i don't know if you know david goggins
is by any chance i do
i mean i don't know him personally but
oh my lord so i'm i'm
running 48 miles together with him in
person in a month
you're doing an ultra marathon with him
and
probably other stuff because he enjoys
just
breaking people making them cry so my
god i'm so jelly
so you know i well i offered we we
agreed a while ago to do a podcast
and he's like oh yeah come we'll do it
this day and this is all the bay area
uh i don't know where the hell he is but
we're doing it and uh i don't think i'm
supposed to say where it is
it's not anywhere close to anywhere in
the middle of nowhere
but he seems to be in a bunch of
different locations like he he's
uh in oregon or something like that like
what does he do for
outside of writing books and being
inspirational does he actually train
people
or like no no he's doing just he's
a full-time insane like he fights forest
fires like
for a few months a year wow as a farmer
like unpaid labor
like he you know there's a bunch of
people who are like him like navy seals
and so on
that kind of make a career out of
motivational speak and all that yeah
he's not interested in any of that he's
literally interested
in uh just doing hard [ __ ] all the time
he's breaking himself breaking himself
he seems like he wants to break himself
and that that book is amazing and the
audiobook's amazing when he's talking
about how fat he was
and how he just had to go and keep
running and his like legs are broken and
he's just
super pain and he just goes through it
it's really inspiring
inspiring thing also are you going to
videotape yourself doing this
i can't wait to see you get destroyed
yeah well this is
so entertaining for the lex audience
the pain uh but the other inspiring
thing is he's uh happily married
oh good and there's a partnership there
that's you know everybody finds a
this attention as a push and pull that's
beautiful i think
you